Prof: So we know
something about all these
powerful tools that had been
developed: quantum mechanics
around 1925, '26 actually;
and then all these much more
modern things,
including scanning probe
microscopy, which is really
quite recent.
But the most powerful tool in
organic chemistry,
for everyday practice,
and certainly for anybody who's
not a professional chemist and
into quantum mechanics and stuff
like that, is bonds;
this amazing invention of
bonds, and how people knew what
things were like before any of
these tools were dreamt of.
Right?
And, for that,
we go back in time and look at
these guys in the nineteenth
century who invented it.
And we begin with what's called
-- whoops -- we begin with --
sorry, here we go again -- okay,
we begin with the Chemical
Revolution.
Right?
That's a name that historians
of science have given this
period, beginning with
Lavoisier.
So really that's where we'll
start.
But he didn't just spring from
nowhere.
There was a long tradition of
some kinds of chemistry before
that, and we're going to just
review that very briefly.
There's a background in ancient
art and lore.
Okay?
So, for example,
here's a mosaic from Montreale,
in Sicily, of Noah,
as making wine and then falling
victim to it and having his
shame hidden by his sons.
Okay?
And here's his flask, right?
Student:  Oh no.
Prof: This is like 3000
years ago.
The mosaic is about 1000 years;
it's twelfth century,
it's 800 or 900 hundred years
old.
Okay?
Here is a Roman glass perfume
vial, that's 2000 years old.
So they made perfume,
obviously, and extracted the
stuff from flowers and whatever
that would do that.
Okay?
There's the Chemical Research
Building when it was five days
old.
Okay?
And we already saw Francis
Bacon who said:
"All the philosophy of
nature which is now received,
is either the philosophy of the
Grecians,
or that of the alchemists."
So the alchemists are in a
sense our ancestors.
He didn't have a very high
opinion of them.
He said: "The one is
gathered out of a few vulgar
observations"
(that's the Greek philosophers)
"and the other out of a few
experiments of a furnace.
The one never faileth to
multiply words,
and the other ever faileth to
multiply gold."
So even at this time,
when science was beginning to
get underway,
modern science,
alchemy was already in
disrepute.
But it did contribute some
things.
It didn't contribute much to
theory, because the theory
depended on Greek,
well on the Greek antecedents
and authority,
rather than observation.
But they did fiddle around.
Here's a painting of an
alchemist from 1663.
And remember,
Newton did more work in alchemy
than he did in physics.
Right?
And he wrote an enormous amount
but never published anything
about it.
There's a great website now,
from the University of Indiana,
of all Newton's alchemical
works, and you can look at them.
But this was to be kept a
secret.
That was the idea of alchemy,
that it was occult,
it was hidden.
Okay?
And in fact there's a show
that's coming up on alchemy at
the Beinecke Library,
in January, of their holdings
in alchemy,
and the title of the show is
"The Book of Secrets."
Right?
And that's Harry Potter
as well, right?
>
So here's one of the things
that's going to be shown.
It's part of a really long
scroll, which is the Visio
Mystica of Arnold of
Villanova,
who was a thirteenth century
alchemist who was into medicine
and was considered the greatest
medical authority of its time.
This particular scroll was
written in England in 1570.
So a lot of it's in English.
It says, "the red sea,
the red lune ,
the red sol ."
Right?
All sorts of mystical things.
And then, and you see here is
the corpus, the body,
which is earth;
and here's the soul,
which is oil;
and here's the spirit or the
air, the breath,
which is water.
So there was -- everything was
a symbol for something else.
Or if you look at the four
corners of this,
on the bottom right we have
air.
Right?
"Eeyre",
it says, "is hott and
moyst."
Right?
Or on the top left is earth,
which is cold and dry;
the opposite of air.
And down here is fire,
which is hot and dry.
And up there is water,
which is cold and moist.
Right?
So this was supposed to be
something profound and
mysterious.
Another thing they're going to
show is this book,
On the Philosopher's
Stone, which was written in
the thirteenth century.
The particular copy they have
is from 1571.
But it looks like somebody's
organic chemistry text,
after they've highlighted it in
preparation for the exam.
Every word is underlined.
>
Right?
And all in the margin are these
fingers pointing to important
things.
Right?
And if you look there,
you'll see great words like
alchemy there,
you see elixir.
I forget, there are a lot of
key words.
But fundamentally it's all
nonsense, all the theory.
The reason people kept it
secret, really,
was, I think,
not to keep other people from
finding it out,
but to hide the fact that it
was nonsense.
That's just my own theory,
so maybe that's wrong.
Okay, but Paracelsus,
in the early 1500s,
was an alchemist,
a traveling physician,
and he developed what had been
long before that,
which was the Doctrine of
Sympathies,
and one aspect of that was in
nature,
antidotes for poisons are to be
found near the source of the
illness.
Right?
So, for example,
you know what that is?
Student:  Poison ivy.
Prof: Poison ivy. Right?
But near poison ivy you're
likely to find jewelweed,
which is an antidote for poison
ivy.
Right?
Or -- poison ivy is a New World
thing, so that didn't interest
the alchemists -- but this one
certainly did.
Willow -- Salix is the Latin
name for willow -- which is
found in malarial swamps.
So you go into a swamp,
you get malaria,
but you also find the willow
there.
And the willow bark,
extracting from the willow bark
you can get Salicin,
a glycoside,
which is a sugar plus an
aromatic thing there.
Right?
And if you hydrolyze that to
get the sugar off,
and oxidize that to make a
carboxylic acid,
you get this.
What's that?
Students:
Salicylic acid.
Prof: Right.
Salicylic acid,
from alix.
Right?
So it's good for fevers and so
on, for your malaria.
Okay, so that's a theory.
This is another thing they're
going to show,
a Vade Mecum -- come
along with me --
which is a lab manual that was
kept by Caspar Harttung vom
Hoff,
in 1557, in Austria.
So you can see he draws various
-- what he's,
he's reading various things,
and writing extracts and notes
to himself about it.
It's like your pre-lab
preparation.
Right?
Okay, and you notice who he's
quoting up here?
Arnold, that guy from the
thirteenth century who did the
thing we've showed first.
Right?
Arnold of Villanova.
Okay, but he shows distillation
apparatus.
These things are called
pelicans.
Isn't that interesting?
And here's a lamp.
And here's somebody,
he's filtering something
through some kind of screen or
grid there.
Okay?
So they developed tools that
were of great use to chemistry,
once chemistry got going.
So there was a lot of -- even
though the theory was nonsense
-- there was a lot of practical
background in preparing various
elixirs and so on.
So this was crucial.
Now here is a lab that could
easily be mistaken for an
alchemical laboratory,
but in fact it's an early
chemical laboratory.
And I'll show it to you here.
It's this book,
it's this picture here from
1777, from a book about Air
and Fire.
And it reports the discovery of
a new element,
in this book.
And it's by Carl Wilhelm
Scheele, who was in Uppsala;
"Upsala", in Sweden.
What do you think he discovered
with light and fire -- or pardon
me, with air and fire;
Luft und dem Feuer?
Student:  Oxygen.
Prof: Ah ha, we'll see.
So that's his laboratory,
Scheele's laboratory,
or at least some artist's
impression of it.
And here he is.
He's before the Chemical
Revolution, but he's an
important precedent,
as you'll see,
to the Chemical Revolution.
He was by practice a pharmacist
but he spent most of his time
doing what is really chemical
research.
Here's a picture of a stamp,
a Swedish stamp,
showing Scheele.
Except it's not Scheele.
It turns out the costume he's
wearing wouldn't have been
developed until forty years
after Scheele died.
Okay, but he purified organic
compounds, that weren't easy to
purify;
in particular, carboxylic acids.
So he got an acid from -- that
he called lactic acid;
which we now know has that
structure.
Where did he get it?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: From sour milk.
Okay?
So here's his paper about that,
"On Milk and its
Acid" from 1780.
So he purified these acids as
salts that he could crystallize.
That was the method of
purifying.
So here's several reports in
that paper.
Item 7: "Bismuth, cobalt,
antimony, tin,
mercury, silver and gold were
attacked by lactic acid,
either by digestion"
(that's just sitting there
under it) "or by boiling.
After standing over tin,
the acid caused a black
precipitate to form in a
solution of gold and aqua
regia." Right?
So this is not mysterious
writing.
Right?
It's talking in language that
we can understand,
even though it's translated
from German.
Iron and zinc were dissolved
with a formation of flammable
air.
What do you suppose -- he
reacted acid with zinc and he
got flammable air.
What do you suppose that was?
Student:  Hydrogen gas.
Prof: Hydrogen, right?
"The iron solution was
brown and gave no
crystallization,
but the zinc solution
crystallized."
Why was that important?
Student:  He could
purify it.
Prof: Because he could
purify it if it crystallized,
and get just that salt.
Right?
So that's how he got pure
samples of acids.
Right?
"With copper,
our solution first took on a
blue color, then green,
finally dark blue,
but did not crystallize";
unfortunately.
And 10: "Lead dissolved
after several days of digestion.
The solution acquired a sweet,
tart taste,"
>
"but did not
crystallize."
Right?
So what do you do when you
don't have IR and NMR,
right?
Student:  Eat.
Student:  Taste.
Prof: Sure.
So he tasted all these things.
Cyanide too.
Okay, so he got citric acid.
Where did he get that?
Student:  Lemons.
Prof: From lemons, okay?
And he got uric acid;
obvious.
He got tartaric acid.
Tartaric acid,
his discovery,
turns out to one of the --
probably the single most
important,
maybe the second,
no probably the most important
compound in the nineteenth
century,
as you'll see.
Okay?
That comes from tartar,
which is the deposit on the
inside of wine casks,
after you've fermented wine.
Okay?
Benzoic acid came from gum
benzoin, a product of the Far
East.
Okay?
And oxalic acid.
Where do you think that came
from?
It came from rhubarb.
Now why oxalic;
why oxy?
Oxy means sharp.
So what does sharp have to do
with it, with rhubarb?
Student:  It has a sharp
taste?
Prof: Yes,
so you know oxy as a
root, meaning sharp.
Oxymoron doesn't mean a stupid
ox.
What it means is sharp,
and moron means dull.
So it's a sharp dullness,
is an oxymoron.
It's a self-contradictory word.
Right?
So what's sharp about rhubarb?
Student:  Its taste.
Prof: Its taste;
it tastes acidic.
In fact, the word acidic
comes from the Latin
acidus;
which comes from acre,
to be sour;
which comes from,
the root is ac,
which means sharp.
So it's the same thing,
acid and oxy.
Okay?
So look at all these things.
They have what?
The carboxylate group,
which makes them acidic.
Right?
And we know why it makes it
acidic;
this is a review from last
time, this functional group.
It's not a carbonyl alcohol,
it's a carboxylic acid.
The high HOMO is stabilized in
the acid.
But it's even more stabilized
when it's an anion,
because you have a higher HOMO.
So it changes the acidity,
the ease of dissociation of
H^+, by a factor of 10^11th.
Right?
Which depends on the energy
difference between those two.
So if you more stabilize the
anion product than you stabilize
the starting material,
then you shift the reaction
toward product,
here by 10^11th;
a big change.
Okay?
But actually there's more to it
than just that resonance,
just that HOMO/LUMO
interaction.
There's a thing called
"inductive effects"
that we'll talk about later on.
But a large part of it is due
to that.
Okay, but you notice there's
one exception here.
Uric acid doesn't have a
carboxylate group in it.
So there's what it has.
And notice that it has an
unshared-pair on nitrogen.
Like an amide,
it's stabilized by a carbonyl;
in fact, it's stabilized by two
carbonyls, two adjacent LUMOs to
stabilize it.
Now if that were just stable,
it wouldn't be a reason to get
rid of it, to lose a proton.
But the anion that you get if
you lose the proton from
nitrogen has a higher HOMO.
So it's even more stabilized.
The same trick as in carboxylic
acid, but even more so,
as you'll see here.
The pK_a of this compound is
5.8.
It's pretty acidic. Right?
But a normal amine,
like ammonia losing a proton,
has a pK_a of 38.
Right?
So this is thirty-two powers of
ten helped out,
because it has such a high HOMO
on the nitrogen,
and two carbonyls to stabilize
it.
Okay, so uric acid is indeed an
acid, like carboxylic acids.
Okay, now Scheele not only did
these organic acids,
he also discovered,
or co-discovered,
seven elements.
They're listed here according
to what row of the periodic
table they're in.
Notice down at the bottom here
you have tungsten.
Right?
Tungsten comes from Swedish.
He was Swedish.
It's "tung"
"sten",
heavy stone.
Being way down,
it's got lots of protons and
neutrons and is very,
very dense.
Right?
So it's heavy -- the stones
that it comes from are very
heavy.
Right?
But by contrast,
these up here are gases.
And in fact that's what got the
19th Century chemistry going.
That's what launched the
Chemical Revolution,
was the ability to work with
gases.
Because to be a gas,
something has to be a small
molecule and therefore simple,
or at least relatively simple.
So you had to start with simple
things before you could get the
complex ones,
like salicylic acid,
in terms of understanding.
Now Scheele,
in 1771, had heated silver
carbonate, and he found that he
got CO_2 out of them;
he didn't know it was CO_2,
but the gas came out.
Okay?
And if you heated that still
more, greater than 340 Celsius,
then you get silver,
and oxygen comes out from
silver oxide;
this gas, this
feuerluft,
fire air.
That's what the book is about.
Okay?
So he wrote the book.
But the book starts,
as I'll show you here --
sorry, there we go -- the book
starts with an introduction,
a
"vorbericht",
which is translated,
it says, from Swedish.
And let's see where it says
here.
And it's by Torbern Bergman,
written in 1777.
He had this book written for
two years, waiting for this
preface to come.
Bergman was a busy guy. Right?
And during the time that this
book was sitting,
ready, the manuscript was
sitting ready to be printed,
Priestley, in England,
discovered oxygen.
So this book came out after
Priestley.
But there's no doubt that
Scheele had discovered it
earlier.
His lab books from 1771 show it.
And here, in 1774,
is his draft of a letter that
he wrote to France.
And it begins -- or it actually
begins with a couple of words on
the previous sheet --
but it says:
"…since I have no
large burning glass,
I beg you to try with
yours..."
Because he had to do this by
heating things in an oven,
at a really high temperature,
which was hard to do.
But if you could do it with a
focused light of the sun to heat
it, then it would be much more
practical.
And, in France,
they had such a big magnifying
glass, that would allow to do
it.
But that letter,
although it was sent,
was never answered.
And you know who it was sent
to, presumably.
Lavoisier, the founder of the
Chemical Revolution,
and another discoverer of
oxygen.
Okay?
Okay, so now we're going to
talk about Lavoisier,
who was -- wasn't a perfect
person, but he was really very,
very good.
Okay, now the Chemical
Revolution.
You can say it started in 1789,
the Chemical Revolution.
And that's not the only
revolution that started in
France in 1789.
Right?
Do you know what this is?
What?
Student:  Tennis Court
Oath.
Prof: It's the Tennis
Court Oath,
when the legislators,
so to say, gathered to say that
they wouldn't disband until the
king granted them certain
things;
and you know what that led to,
in 1789.
The only guy that didn't agree
was this guy here.
He's the only one that didn't
sign it.
But at any rate, it was radical.
Now there's an Indo-European
word, that's the root of many
words, called Werad;
and it gives words in all sorts
of languages.
Like it means root.
Okay?
And Wurzel,
in German, means root;
and wort,
like St.
John's wort,
is a root.
Licorice;
glukos rhiza,
Greek, the rhiza is
root;
sweet root it means.
Okay?
Race;
razza in Italian is the
root of your being.
Right?
Rutabaga.
Radix in Latin;
and you know lots of words come
from radix,
like radish is a root.
Or eradicate,
what does that mean?
Prof: It means to pull
it out by the roots.
Okay?
Or radical;
something that's radical is
something that goes right to the
root, back to the very origin of
something.
And that word,
used in that way,
if you look in the Oxford
English Dictionary,
it was coined in mathematics in
the 16th Century.
The root of a number is its
origin.
Right?
If you take the square root of
a number, and multiply it by
itself, you get the number.
So it's the root of the number;
the radical. Right?
Or in politics,
it was used in 18th Century in
England,
and in chemistry,
in 18th Century in France,
the idea of radical as the root
of things,
began to be used;
which we'll see.
Okay, so 1787,
radical was introduced as a
political term,
according to the Oxford English
Dictionary, by J. Jebb,
whoever he was;
presumably a politician.
Or in 1787, there was this
radical document,
"We the People."
Right?
But that same year,
1787, radical was introduced as
a chemical term,
by Louis Bernard Guyton de
Morveau.
And it was in the context of
developing nomenclature for
chemistry.
So he, together with Berthollet
and Fourcroy,
developed a new method for
nomenclature in chemistry.
And here's a book.
This is not the original
French, but it's the first
English translation,
which you see comes from the
Yale University Library,
back when.
It's from 1788.
Okay?
So A Method of Chemical
Nomenclature,
by Guyton de Morveau,
Lavoisier, Berthollet and
Fourcroy.
So the fourth author of this
new method of chemical
nomenclature is Lavoisier.
So there's Lavoisier with his
wife.
This is part of an enormous
picture that's in the
Metropolitan.
It was commissioned by
Lavoisier and his wife,
who hired Jacques-Louis David
to paint it.
And they paid 7000 pounds,
to the artist to paint it;
which is the equivalent of
$300,000 today.
They were quite well-to-do.
They had an income of the order
of a million dollars a year,
or the equivalent;
it depends on how you translate
numbers, of course.
It's hard.
So here he is at the age of 45,
in 1789,
and he's working on drafting --
so these guys,
when they had their portraits
painted,
always put something important
in it.
So what did he choose to have?
He chose to be working on a
manuscript, and the manuscript
he's working on is the
manuscript of this book,
from 1789.
It's called Traité
Élémentaire de
Chimie;
the Elementary Treatise on
Chemistry.
And the other stuff he put in
the picture is the equipment he
used.
So here you see various
equipment from one of the plates
at the end of the book.
And you can see these items in
the picture.
There's that bell jar.
There's that device.
There's that big sixteen-pint
flask, with a brass fitting on
it.
There's that valve that you
attach to the bottom of the
flask.
And over here is a portfolio,
and the portfolio says,
down in the corner,
"Paulze Lavoisier
sculpsit."
That means this was drawn by
Paulze Lavoisier,
who was his wife.
She was his assistant in the
laboratory, kept all the
notebooks;
read English for him,
because he couldn't read
English.
So if he had to do anything
with Priestley,
she would read it to him.
But she drew all these things.
She studied with David,
drawing, in order to be able to
do this.
Okay, she painted this portrait
of their family friend.
Who's that?
Student:  Benjamin
Franklin.
Prof: Yes,
Benjamin Franklin.
I showed you that picture
earlier, said we'd refer to it
again.
So this is that particular
plate in the book,
and it relates to weighing a
gas.
It'll turn out that the most
important thing for Lavoisier,
and for the whole 19th Century
-- all this development that led
to bonds and their arrangement
--
weighing was the key thing.
But how do you weigh a gas?
So you need gases so they're
simple enough to deal with,
and easy to purify.
Right?
But you need to weigh them.
So how can you weigh a gas?
Well you can collect a gas,
as shown in this picture,
by generating it in this retort
G, and it comes and it bubbles
up,
displacing water or mercury,
most often mercury,
from a bell jar.
You've done this kind of thing?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Some of you.
But you can see how it would
work;
as it bubbles up the mercury
comes down.
Okay.
So now you have the gas.
Now we'll shift attention down
to the bottom right here,
and see how this works.
So we have this bell jar on the
bottom,
which is fitted with valves on
the top,
is filled with mercury,
and it's in a pool of mercury,
and then this big sixteen-pint
flask is evacuated.
You use one of these pumps.
Remember, 100 years before
this, Hooke -- or 130 years
before this -- Hooke made a
great vacuum pump for Boyle.
Boyle is the only person on the
front of the building older than
Lavoisier.
Right?
And that was dealing with gases
and Boyle's Law,
how pressure and volume relate
to one another.
Okay, so anyhow,
he could evacuate that with a
pump, then seal it off,
turn the valves off.
And he's got mercury in that
thing.
And now he puts a tip
underneath it and generates gas.
And it bubbles up and fills
this container with a gas.
And it's sitting in a mercury
pool so that it's not
communicating with the
atmosphere, other than through
the pressure,
through the mercury pool.
Okay, so now he opens the
valves.
So the vacuum starts sucking up
the mercury;
that is, pulling the air in,
up to a certain point.
Right?
Then the mercury stops rising.
Okay?
And now, at this point you know
that the pressure of that gas is
atmospheric pressure,
less whatever the height of the
mercury column is.
Right?
That's how a barometer works.
So he knows how much gas,
what volume of gas he has in A.
He filled it with water first
and weighed it to see what its
volume was.
Now he knows the volume,
he knows the pressure.
So he knows how much gas there
would be, at atmospheric
pressure.
Right?
And now, of course,
he just turns off these things,
unscrews one,
the thing on top,
and weighs it,
and sees how much heavier it is
than it was when it was
evacuated.
And that's how much the air
weighs.
And he knows how much volume,
how much pressure.
So he knows how much whatever
gas he collected weighed.
So he could weigh a gas.
Pretty clever, huh?
Okay, here he is working with
one of these bell jars.
Now these bell jars were filled
with mercury.
I don't know if you've -- here,
would you help me out Wilson?
Lift this up and show it to the
class.
But don't lift it high,
hold it above the thing.
Did it surprise you?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: He said it
surprised him.
And you can come up afterwards,
if you want to,
and be surprised yourself,
by lifting this up.
But keep it over this,
because people are so panicked
about mercury nowadays.
I heard on the way over to
class, while I was bringing
this,
I heard there's a new law in
the European Union that it's
going to be illegal to transport
mercury over international
borders.
Go figure.
Anyhow, there's Lavoisier doing
an experiment with this big
thing of mercury.
Right?
He must've been a stout person.
Okay?
This is him in his library,
with Madame Lavoisier taking
his dictation,
as he does his experiments.
Okay, so here's the
Traité
Élémentaire de
Chimie,
and I'll show you the -- this
actually is a facsimile,
not the real thing.
But here's the title page of
the first volume.
Okay.
So you can look at that if you
want to.
And at the end,
I'll just note here,
at the end of the second
volume, are all these pages,
which are devices -- like
here's this is the one we just
looked at.
Okay?
So if you want to look at them,
feel free.
Don't handle the other one
though;
it's real.
Okay, so Elementary Treatise
of Chemistry,
Presented in a New Order
-- this is the Revolution --
According to Modern
Discoveries,
With Figures;
as I just showed you.
And 1789 is the date,
the same as the French
Revolution.
Okay, you notice he's a member
of all different academies,
including Philadelphia.
Why in the world would he have
been a member of the Scientific
Academy of Philadelphia?
He never went there.
Student:  Ben Franklin
was --
Prof: Right, his pal.
Okay, 1789.
So it has the most wonderful
Introduction,
called "Discours
Préliminaire."
And he says:
"My only object,
when I began this work" --
or, "I had no other object
when I began the following work,
than to extend and explain more
fully the memoir,
which I read at the public
meeting of the Academy of
Science in the month of April,
1787" (remember when
radical was introduced and so
on) "on the necessity of
reforming and completing the
nomenclature of Chemistry."
So that's all he was trying to
do was get a proper nomenclature
that would be useful,
in contrast to all this
alchemical nonsense.
Okay?
"While engaged in this
employment,
I perceived,
better than I had ever done
before,
the justice of the following
maxims of the Abbé
de Condillac and his System of
Logic and some other
works."
So this is what Condillac said.
"We think,
only through the medium of
words.
Languages are true analytical
methods.
Algebra, which is adapted to
its purpose in every species of
expression,
in the most simple,
most exact, and best manner
possible,
is at the same time a language
and an analytical method.
The art of reasoning is nothing
more than language,
well arranged."
So Lavoisier goes on to say:
"Thus, while I thought
myself employed only in forming
a Nomenclature,
and while I proposed to myself
nothing more than to improve the
chemical language,
my work transformed itself by
degrees,
without my being able to
prevent it,
into a treatise upon the
Elements of Chemistry."
So in the process of reforming
the language,
he reformed the whole
understanding of the science.
"The impossibility of
separating nomenclature of a
science from the science itself,
is owing to this,
that every branch of physical
science must consist of three
things;
the series of facts
which are the object of the
science,
the ideas which
represent these facts,
and the words by which
the ideas are expressed.
Like three impressions of the
same seal, the word ought to
produce the idea,
and the idea to be a picture of
the fact."
So all these things have to be
harmonious.
Right?
Three impressions of the same
seal.
"And, as ideas are
preserved and communicated by
means of words,
it necessarily follows that we
cannot improve the language of
any science without at the same
time improving the science
itself;
neither can we,
on the other hand,
improve a science,
without improving the language
or nomenclature which belongs to
it.
However certain the facts of
any science may be,
however just the ideas we may
have formed of these facts,
we can only communicate false
impressions to others,
while we want words by which
these may be properly
expressed."
Right?
So clarity, as opposed to
obscurity, was his goal;
as opposed to Newton or the
alchemists.
Right?
Facts, ideas and words,
and they all have to tie into
one another as impressions of
the same seal.
Okay?
So he presented things,
as he had advertised,
in a new order;
very different from any book on
chemistry that had been written
before.
First was doctrine,
-- that is, the theory -- the
first part of the book,
which is a two-volume book.
So almost all of the first --
no, about two-thirds,
I think, of the first volume
are doctrine.
And then nomenclature;
that's what he had set out to
do.
And finally operations,
how you can actually repeat
this stuff for yourself,
what devices you need.
Of course, he was very wealthy
and could employ people to
manufacture all the equipment he
needed;
not everybody could do that.
But he showed exactly how it
was done and gave great -- it's
easy to understand exactly what
he did.
Now, one of the first things he
turned his attention to was
elements.
He says:
"…if by the name
elements we mean to designate
the simple,
indivisible molecules"
(molecule just means little
thing, right?) "that make
up substances,
it is probable we do not know
what they are."
(They're just too small. Right?)
"But if,
on the contrary,
we associate with the name of
elements,
or the principles of
substances, the idea of the
furthest stage to which analysis
can reach,
all substances that we have so
far found no means to decompose
are elements for us…
they behave with respect to us
like simple substances."
So it's an operational,
not a philosophical,
definition of element.
If you can't break it apart,
consider it an element until
you can break it apart.
We have elements here,
the chemical elements.
Are they elements,
according to Lavoisier's
definition?
Like here we see cerium,
praseodymium,
neodymium, promethium,
samarium, europium,
gadolinium.
Are they elements,
according to Lavoisier?
Students:  No.
Prof: Why not?
Students:
You can break them.
Prof: You can break them
apart, into nuclei and
electrons.
The nuclei you can break apart
into protons and neutrons,
and you can break these things
apart into quarks and so on.
But, for Lavoisier,
or for chemists,
those are elements,
because you don't break them
apart.
Okay?
So here's a table of simple
substances,
in the first English
translation of the
Traité
Élémentaire de
Chimie.
So here's a table of the
elements: "Simple
substances belonging to all the
kingdoms of nature,
which may be considered as the
elements of bodies."
So what are the first two
elements, things that you can't
break apart?
Student:  Light.
Prof: Light and heat are
the first two elements -- which
we don't see in Mendeleev's
table, right?
Because they're fundamentally
different from the other
elements, because they don't
have any weight.
You can weigh a gas but you
can't weigh light,
and you can't weigh heat.
Okay?
So he gives new names to these
things -- light and caloric --
and what the old name was.
Light used to be called light
too, but in his new system he's
going to keep the old name;
or "caloric",
he's going to use for what used
to be called heat;
or "the principle or
element of heat";
or "fire";
or "igneous fluid";
or "the matter of fire or
heat".
Those were terms people had
used before, but he's going to
call them "caloric".
Okay?
Now, if you have caloric,
you must be able to measure it.
If you can't weigh it,
what you can do;
you can use a
"calorimeter"
to measure it.
And this is the calorimeter
manufactured and used by
Lavoisier;
and also Laplace,
a younger man who was his
colleague, who became a great
mathematician,
as you probably know.
So here's the thing.
It's big.
That's a three-foot rule.
So this thing stood this high
off the table,
right?
Okay?
Now here's what it is.
There's a lamp that's going to
make fire.
There's oil in the well of the
lamp.
You're going to measure how
much heat you get out of burning
that oil.
So you put it inside this
bucket, and you put the bucket
in this mesh cage and put the
lid on.
Then you put that cage,
and its lid,
up into this can.
Okay?
And now you light the flame,
in there.
You want to measure how much
heat it gives.
How do you measure the heat?
What you do is surround it by
melting ice.
So the heat will melt the ice.
Now there's going to be a
problem.
Obviously the more heat,
the more ice you melt.
But that's not the only place
heat's coming from.
Where else will it come from,
to melt the ice?
Students:  Outside.
Prof: From outside.
So this is where the thing is
clever.
So there's another can,
outside that can,
and you fill it with ice,
which is an insulator,
for the inside.
So no heat comes from the --
any heat that comes from the
outside, melts the outside ice,
not the inside ice.
Only the flame will melt the
inside ice.
Okay, and notice that the lids
also are covered with ice too.
So it's completely surrounded
by ice, and then by another
layer of ice.
So your flame burns,
burns, burns,
burns.
And you fill -- water comes up
as they melt in both of them.
And then you put that thing
underneath and turn the tap,
and see how much water was
melted;
only by the flame, right?
And that measures how much heat.
Pretty clever, huh?
Okay, so that's a fact,
is measuring how much heat
there is.
But analysis in general is it.
This is from the Oxford English
Dictionary, which Yale has a
subscription to.
So you can look up words to
your heart's content.
It's a lot of fun.
This year is the 80th
anniversary of the Oxford
English Dictionary.
There was a symposium,
down the hill,
sponsored by the library,
including the guy that wrote
that The Professor and the
Madman.
Has anyone read that book about
the Oxford English Dictionary?
It's a wonderful short book,
and the madman was a Yale
graduate.
Really, it's an interesting
story.
And the other guy was one who
read the Oxford English
Dictionary, cover to cover,
20 volumes, within one year.
He wrote a book about that,
during the last year.
It was a fun thing.
But anyhow, this is -- it's fun
to look up things in the Oxford
English Dictionary.
And here's analysis.
So you see it comes from
ana, and I think it's
lisein;
but I can get some help on that.
Student:  luein.
Prof: luein, okay.
Anyhow, but it means "to
loose," according to the
Oxford English Dictionary.
So it's to loose back;
to take things apart is the
sense of it.
And generally it's the
resolution or breaking up of
anything complex into its
various simple elements.
So you can analyze a passage in
literature.
Okay?
It's the opposite of synthesis.
"The exact determination
of the elements or components of
anything complex;
specifically in chemistry,
the resolution of a chemical
compound into its proximate,
or ultimate,
elements."
Now, proximate and ultimate,
what does that mean?
You can see down in the
historical uses of it what
proximate and ultimate
mean.
1791, this same time -- 1789,
remember,
was the Traité
Élémentaire
--
said, "the quantity of
charcoal,
which something yields by
analysis."
So you find out how much
charcoal is in it.
That's the word -- we now say
carbon.
So that's elemental analysis.
That's ultimate analysis;
take things all apart to the
chemical elements,
see how much of each one.
But there's also this thing
called proximate
analysis,
which you can see from this
quote in 1831.
"Sugar,
starch and gum are proximate
principles, and these we
obtained by proximate
analysis."
So you can take some foodstuff
and see what percentage of
protein, what percentage of
sugar, or what percentage of
this, that and the other thing.
So what you read on a candy
bar, or something like that,
that's proximate analysis,
not elemental,
not ultimate analysis.
So both kinds are important in
Lavoisier's work,
as we'll see.
Okay, so we looked at light and
caloric.
Now let's look at a few of
these elements,
the ultimate elements here.
He had the fact,
the theory and the word for
these things.
So how about Azote?
Why is that word -- that's the
French name for --
the French still call nitrogen
azote,
and in this English translation
it was called that in 1790 or
'91.
Okay, where does that word come
from?
What does the prefix a
mean?
Student:  Without.
Prof: Without.
And how about zo?
It's great we have somebody
taking Greek.
Student:  Life.
Prof: Without life.
In what sense is that an
appropriate name,
a meaningful name for nitrogen?
Alex?
Student:  I think they
performed the tests on nitrogen
first and it was --
Prof: What kind of tests?
Student:  They would
suffocate like a bird in
nitrogen.
Prof: Yes,
if you put a mouse in an
atmosphere of nitrogen,
it's azote.
Right?
So that's what the name meant.
It used to be called
phlogisticated air,
or gas, or mephitis,
or the base of mephitis.
Right?
Azote is the name that
Lavoisier decided to use for it.
Or hydro-gen.
How about it, help us out?
Student:  Hdor
would've been water.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Water.
Prof: What about water?
Hydro is water.
What's gen?
Student:  To leave water.
Prof: It makes water.
Right?
So if you burn hydro-gen,
you generate water.
Right?
So hydrogen.
Okay.
How about oxy-gen?
What does it generate?
Students:  Acid.
Prof: Acid, sourness.
So oxygen is the element that
generates sourness,
that generates acid.
And that is the key element in
Lavoisier's theory,
the oxygen theory of
combustion.
Okay, so oxygen,
plus a base,
or radical -- right?
So these two terms meant the
same thing to Lavoisier,
the fundamental radical,
the root of some substance,
right?
And you react it with oxygen
and it makes the stuff into an
acid.
Can you think of an example of
an element that you react with
oxygen and it becomes an acid?
Well let's just look in his
table.
Sulfur;
you burn it and it becomes
sulfuric acid,
or sulfurous acid.
Right?
Phosphorous generates
phosphoric acid.
Carbon generates carbonic acid.
Muriatic radical -- which we
don't know;
they haven't discovered the
muriatic radical yet,
the base of that acid -- but if
you burn it and combine it with
oxygen, you get muriatic acid.
Does anybody know what muriatic
acid is?
Student:  Hydrochloric
acid.
Prof: Hydrochloric acid.
How much oxygen is in it?
Student:  None.
Prof: None, right?
But that was the theory,
that you take a base,
you react it with oxygen,
you get an acid.
So there must have been a
muriatic radical.
Okay?
Unfortunately that part of it
was wrong.
The same for fluoric radical.
Okay?
But then there were also
compound radicals,
radicals that were only
proximate, not ultimate;
radicals that had several other
elements in them.
Right?
And here were some of those,
a list of those radicals,
with the names that Lavoisier
decided to use for them.
And many of them,
all the ones indicated by an
arrow, are ones that Scheele had
already discovered;
like tartaric,
citric, oxalic,
benzoic, lactic.
Lithic acid was another one
that I didn't mention before,
which comes from stones;
see, it's from urinary calculus.
Okay, so those were compound
radicals.
And that's the end of today's
lecture.